Joshua Davis wrote in the say I need a
lot of help with marketing my tutoring
business and with establishing
complementary strategic partnerships so
full disclosure Josh I I don't know next
I know next to nothing about about
tutoring I'll just put I'll put that out
there but as I as I was thinking about
that and I was finding myself going to
Google to Google tutoring businesses I
was just singing myself well how many
other people know next to nothing about
tutoring or probably doing the same
thing that I'm doing here it's just
googling and if anyone's familiar out
there with the likes of a patch fling or
someone like that smart passive income
this is something that they make their
tons of tons of monthly recurring
revenue on it's just having no sites
that are just content kings and just
really speak well to the content that
people are looking for so this might be
an idea Josh it's just one of the ideas
I had for you in terms of just being
able to have a site that speaks to the
content that people are searching for
you know and then some other verticals
that you might want to hash out and
really look into is this the educational
software vertical I know education
software is popping up everywhere I have
a one-year-old in daycare that uses a
tool called tadpoles that sends us
emails throughout the day letting us
know how the children are doing what
they're up to
so it's everywhere starting at 1 years
old so I'm sure that there's there's
others out there that you can you can
reach out to and partner up with yeah
I'm I'm on board with that too and I
think what I love the sea is is showing
your passion for the business like why
do you care about your doing do you have
your own kids tell me the story behind
it because a lot of you know I have I
have a six-year-old son and I've seen
some of the tutoring websites and they
all kind of seem the same yeah they all
seem very impersonal where if you showed
me like a real human being your story
your kids you know delighted clients
that's gonna help make you stand out at
least in my mind and if you're reaching
out the
murrs or partners or media having a
store that they can tell easily that
separates you from everybody else I
think that passionate store can help be
the differentiator for you absolutely